you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme campaigners say the
government's credibility as hosts of the
cop 26 summit is at risk
as a new oil field in the north sea
awaits final approval to begin
production we find out how transforming
a moor near manchester into a giant
sponge is helping reduce greenhouse gas
emissions
and can gaming make us greener
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show
now today boris johnson and the labour
leader sakir stama have been out
visiting
separate wind farms the prime minister
is hoping to highlight the role of
renewable energy
ahead of the cop 26 climate summit
taking place in glasgow in november
but he's facing criticism for not
matching policy
with rhetoric well just a few hundred
miles from glasgow in the north sea
sits the cambo oil field it's awaiting
final approval to go into production
but critics say giving it the go-ahead
would significantly damage the
government's credibility
just months ahead of cop so here's what
the prime minister had to say after his
visit to the moray east offshore wind
farm
this was a contract that was signed in
was agreed in 2001 and we can't just
tear up
uh contracts as a process to be gone
through but what we need to do
is use this incredible potential of wind
power
and turbines like this haven't been
going up they've only been going up in
the last
four or five years the size that you're
looking at now and they're going to get
even bigger so the potential is
absolutely enormous
well our political correspondent joe
pike is in aberdeen for us so joe
a bit of a green political standoff
going on there certainly
is anna boris johnson is in
aberdeenshire today wanting to focus on
wind power as you say investment in
green technology but at the same time
very difficult
questions being asked about how
committed the government really are to
tackling
climate change especially as you say
because this cambo oil field
is likely to be approved very soon
environmental groups
like oxfam estimate that if it does go
ahead 132 million
tons of co2 will be released now boris
johnson was asked yesterday while he was
in scotland
what he thought of the development he
said then he wasn't aware
today kiyosama in glasgow had a much
clearer position
no i don't think that we should go ahead
with cambo
exploration and oil field we are about
to have cop26 here
in scotland in glasgow which is all
about bringing the world together
to take really hard decisions about how
we take the urgent action that's
necessary on climate change
it is completely inconsistent with that
what we need now is a conversation
about how we transition a dr just
transition
but government sources say this is in
the hands of regulators
initial approval to explore the field
was given
20 years ago and if they were to
say no to final approval it could all
end up
in the courts what this does though show
anna is that government decisions
around the climate around energy have
far more scrutiny than they did
a matter of years ago and that clearly
is due to the upcoming clop
cop climate conference in glasgow this
november
joe thanks very much so boris johnson
and kearstarma out visiting wind farms
there
so let's take a quick look at our data
dashboard to see where electricity in
great britain
is coming from today and as you can see
around 26
is coming from fossil fuels we've got 56
coming from renewable sources that
includes wind power
and then 18 from nuclear
now in today's other climate news
campaigners are calling for the end of
driven grouse shooting in at least
10 percent of britain's national parks
research by rewilding britain
found 842 000 acres of protected land
are taken up by intensely managed grouse
moors causing biodiversity loss
and damaging soil the moorland
association
strongly dispute the findings saying
grouse moore managers are committed
to conservation efforts the densest
air quality sensor network in the world
is being installed in north london
to improve people's health and wellbeing
250 advanced air quality sensors will be
fitted on
lamp posts and buildings across camden
and refresh
60 times more frequently than existing
stations
it's hoped the data could help people
map journeys using roots
that have the least air pollution and a
breeding programme
set up to reintroduce ospreys to england
has seen its 200th
chick fledge the female chick will stay
in rutland until september
when it'll head off on a 3 000 mile
migration journey
to the west coast of africa the rutland
osprey project was set up in 1996
more than 150 years after the birds
became extinct
in england and wales to the united
states now and a significant move from
president biden on electric vehicles
well our u.s correspondent mark stone is
in washington for us
so mark what's this all about then well
this is a pledge by uh president biden
to make
half of all electric vehicles all
vehicle sales in the united states by
2030 to be
electric now that is a a massive
commitment he's signing an executive
order
to try and make this happen it's not
binding though and i think some experts
are saying this isn't quite as ambitious
as perhaps it could be
you know i was driving to the office
this morning not in an electric vehicle
and it was quite clear around me here in
dc that hardly any vehicles are electric
and i was looking
at the statistics and they stand that up
you know two percent of
vehicles um in in the united states are
electric compare that to europe 10
percent
the uk 11 china even
5 of the market share is electric so
this gas
guzzling nation is lagging well behind
and this is an attempt by president
biden
with the buy-in it seems of the big car
manufacturers to change that
mark thanks very much indeed last month
was the second warmest july on record
in europe and the third warmest globally
the data from the copernicus climate
change service
shows heatwave conditions were
especially severe in southeastern europe
at the end of the month
warmer than average conditions extended
eastward across most of
asia and the exceptional warmth over the
western u.s and canada
continued from june and the extreme heat
in europe has led to severe wildfires
you can see more about how parts of
turkey have been devastated by flames
in the weekly climate show that's
available on sky news social channels
our app
and our website now pete
is a climate superhero in the uk alone
peatlands hold
around the same amount of carbon as all
the forests in the uk
france and germany combined but much of
it is damaged or dried out
meaning it emits carbon rather than
storing it
well now conservationists are working on
a solution as our science correspondent
thomas moore reports
on the lancashire hills they've created
a giant sponge
dotted across holcomb moore are more
than 3 000 pools
dug into the peat they should slow the
flow of water that used to flood the
towns below
this is a sphagnum plug nick helped
plant half a million patches of moss
that should thrive in the boggy
conditions it takes many times its own
weight in in in water
um so again it's quite right to say it's
a sponge it's like a giant sponge over
over 100 hectares that we're trying to
create here and this little plant here
that's been
around for millennia we always knew
we're important
but really is relevant to modern day
society because this little plant
can is the key to all the success on
this on this project
in a healthy bog the moss sucks in
carbon from the air as it grows
when it dies it doesn't rot because the
ground is so wet
it becomes peat with the carbon locked
away for thousands of years
but on holcomb moor over grazing by
sheep and 150 years of air pollution
have destroyed the fragile moss blanket
a little bit that's been exposed
during the moorland works and you can
see that this has dried out because
um it's been on the surface and you can
see how crumbly it is
and it just the wind takes it and any
water would just take that away
and degrade it and once you start to get
gullies then
you know it just exacerbates the problem
so once it's all vegetated then the
peat's
protected but this success is barely a
hundred hectares
the peat problem is far bigger peat
covers
three million hectares in the uk and it
stores
three billion tons of carbon that's more
than all the forests of the uk
france and germany put together but it
is so
dry that it's releasing 20 million tons
of carbon every year that's
four percent of the uk's annual
emissions
the government says it will now fund
larger projects elsewhere
we've made a commitment to restore 35
000
hectares of peatland by 2025 well that's
only in four years time
and we've already got the measures in
place to set that in motion
repairing the damage took six months but
the benefits will be felt for
generations to come thomas more sky news
on holcomb moore now a new wave of video
games
are rewarding players for making
eco-friendly decisions
in the hope that actions in virtual
worlds
will help encourage real life changes
too now there are more than 44 million
video gamers in the uk
and the industry has grown to become the
country's most lucrative entertainment
sector
more than video and music combined
globally
2.7 billion people play video games and
that's expected to rise to more than 3
billion
by 2023 it's hoped this huge global
audience could start to make a
difference to climate change
now the un believes that video games can
be used to encourage people
to make greener choices and it's working
with companies to explore how games
could address themes
like reforestation and renewable energy
so can gaming make us greener sky's
victoria seabrook has been to find out
a video game with a message we shouldn't
have gone so deep
subnautica is one of a wave of games
trying to tackle climate change
warning players about threats to the
natural world and rewarding them for
protecting it
our world is in free fall
designers say they want their players to
turn the virtual
into reality we wanted people to feel
inspired by what they did as alba
and actions and change their own habits
um outside of the game ecosystem
and parents have got in touch saying
that their children have been begging
them to go and do bird watching and to
go and
do a beach cleanup gaming is everywhere
it's in our homes and on our phones
one in three people on the planet play
what happened to this place
the industry says it can simulate things
like climate change that can otherwise
be hard to imagine
but whether it can really change us is
unclear while we can confidently say
that there's some research which
indicates that people might change how
they think about sustainability in the
environment while they're playing the
game
we're less clear on how those changes
then translate into the real world
and whether they last in the long term
as for the players themselves
our green storylines are win the more
realistic and the more immersive the
game can be
then the more you are definitely going
to play it i don't think that it's
necessarily impacting the
industry i don't think that it's
necessarily impacting consumers the
smaller things that these games are
talking about with
you know recycling and and properly
disposing of plastics and things
they're things that everyone can do of
course like any industry gaming has its
own carbon footprint to clean up
from energy use to electronic waste it
will have to win these battles too
if it wants to go truly green victoria
seabrook sky news
and if you really want to immerse
yourself in the world of green gaming
then tune into this week's
sky news climate cast where we put the
green nudging theory to the test
it's out tomorrow and you can find it
wherever you normally get your podcast
from
well that's everything from us for today
coming up on tomorrow's show
the tension between protecting farms and
looking after a much-loved native
species
as a row over culling beavers in
scotland plays out in the courts
you can catch that at the same time here
on sky news see you then
you